this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you and thanks the opportunity to
come here and is said it's because of
basically being hazed suggestion that we
put that people could look at at what
we're doing so this really about two
screens anyway it'll confuse me or even
more but that's alright with I'm going
to talk about survey based methods and
the design of breeding programs and how
we use them and how we've come to use
them in mostly in animal breeding button
and plant breeding as well so I'm gonna
talk a little I'm going to give you a
description briefly about whatever
conspirers talk a little about why we've
done serve at when we got involved in
survey based methods talk about how we
go from breeding objective deflection
indexes using these business information
we get and a little bit of perspective
on why we engage with users of misplay
and what's different about it how we
approach the whole thing and we use a
combination of demographic surveys in
1,000 minus couple of applications and
ones in pasture plants and ones in dairy
application and then some of the
principles of that and in how they might
apply in mixed in cassava and our
connection with next-gen cassava is a
really balligan who's from Nigeria is
doing a PhD at the University of Otago
but she's actually located in every case
bio officers and the need near office
and the need and see her PhD he's got a
this goes into this survey stuff and
associated with nutrition and in the of
people okay so whatever conspire okay we
are a we're a our scrap line as printing
science and business we exist to
basically to get science and out from
science out from lab type stuff and we
started that 18 years ago because we
said she saw a gap where the science was
getting more conflicts officially with
genomics coming in and all the DNA based
technologies coming in fishy and animal
breeding and it was getting harder and
harder to get it into how that will be
put into the application from the
practical applications their mission is
to make a difference to food production
internationally using science and
technology okay how do we do this our
core capability is actually in genetic
improvement and that's where we've got a
lot of people who have trained in
livestock virtually always livestock
breeding and in with a very strong lot
of them - with a very strong component
of mathematics in statistics we in order
to keeping our feet on the ground we
have we have people working in farm
systems and increasingly in
environmental applications and then and
then the our core in genetics has led us
into a lot more technology data
analytics and a lot more economic
analysis strategic analysis and that's
probably what I do most of now is
looking at biological economic scenarios
for customers okay that's what we do our
global footprint we off radio out of New
Zealand and go to office in New Zealand
one in Dunedin in the south right down
here there and one in Rotorua which from
the middle of North Ireland and then in
Edinburgh which is up there and the one
that the office in the north in the
North Island in Rotorua is where we do
have our plantation forestry group who
have just actually emerged with us there
were a simple company and just moves
with us agility and in the office and in
Barrow is basically the same full of
things then we interact very strongly
with those two groups we operate a
number of different breeds we operated a
number of different countries you'll see
we've just done a major project in the
u.s. in in right so we just don't a
major project than the US with American
Angus and we're doing another one
American Angus cattle and we're just
doing another project in Canada as well
and we've got projects and Ethiopia in
small ruminants and we've got a project
in Saudi Arabia
in development women and some breeding
and in agricultural development with
livestock okay what do we do these are
the sort of species ever conspire we're
known internationally for what we do in
breeding program design and data and the
financial analysis associated with
modeling so we work in sheep we work in
beef cattle we work in dairy cattle we
work in seven honeybees more recently
and deer farm deer and in implantation
forestry so these the areas we work in
the backgrounds of our interest in the
sea origin our interest in this is that
we were involved in development of
breeding objectives and selection tools
in animal breeding and ocean you come
out of a fishy a tell of an animal
breeding background know the breeding
objective in animal breeding is a
critical facet and at a sign of the
breeding program it's commonly built on
bio economic models of the enterprise
that make sense so their buyer is driven
off understanding and enterprise like a
farm and in saying okay what would
influence
where where's the money gets quit as the
revenue come from where does the money
get spin and the breeding objective is a
profit function it's a marginal change
in profit is a function of a change in
the revenue and a change in the cost
it's pretty basic and then but
biomechanoid models can be deficient in
accounting for many usury for some user
requirements and these are traits that
are difficult to define in economic
terms or we users may regard them as
more important there's a really good
examples of this's and disease and
animals disease disease issues are
usually much bigger issues for farmers
than they ever are in terms of the
economic cost and we've got a number of
situations where that whatever it's a
bit now so thinking about other ways to
get at the truth
and when people buying in animals they
don't always buy just on economic things
they buy or they buy on other things
they might for example by on what on
something they believe might especially
well heat resistance or something like
that
and these things are quite hard to turn
into to incorporate into biome economic
models
and there these are situations where
users regard a traitor's more important
than any financial model might indicate
I've got some examples of it later so
I'll give you an example in sheep pretty
straightforward one it's fundamentally
the revenue from sheet comes from
selling lamb meat surplus animals and
from wool and the costs come from animal
health later and fee so you can imagine
in a sheep business there you revving
your lines and they your pay your cost
lines so you can create an a a bio
economic model for that however when you
come to talk to farmers you find it to
issues animal health and labour a far
more importance of them than the
economic cost really good example and
labor is there if you're running a few
thousand sheep and you've got increase
in labour requirement for some reason it
might be because of disease issues or it
might be just because of the nature of
your animals you have to increase by a
later unit it's a very big change in
costs as a major influence in the dairy
industry in New Zealand in terms of the
number of cows that are milked
because these elements a pastoral kennel
system so the number of cows in a milk
actually governs the size of herds so if
you have to increase the number of
animals you either if you have to air a
lady unit that's a major decision making
animal Health's an element where there's
big issues around where the cost of
animal health might be something but
animal health costs often have a
spasmodic component a stochastic about
and that's a real problem for farmers in
terms of how to manage so resistance to
disease it's often a very big trait of
importance so why do we get into this
well we hit a bit of a history in epic
Aspire we honor Murray Neilson came and
worked for us for about a year and Peter
OMA is one of our guys and they came up
with an approach to derive economic
weights in breeding objectives using
profile they published their paper in
2007 and animal but one of the dilemmas
was that there was a scarcity of
software packages to generate the design
and then
workshop birthing one day and I heard
Paul Henson talk and he just lived just
down the road and he was he had
developed 1,000 my and Fran Samba had
developed a tool called 1,000 Minds
which they published and it was
originally devised for prioritizing
surgery surgery in the health scheme so
it's now used to put this expert opinion
is now used to prioritize I think about
16 different types of surgery in the New
Zealand health scheme it's fundamentally
generates a preference based points
based system
um and interestingly year ago two years
ago it was used to prioritize the
antibiotic resistant bacteria issues for
the World Health Organization
so Paul tensions are co-author on this
paper and they flew him in to Geneva
rotting in Geneva to in fact work
through thousand minds with a group of
experts they had there to work out to
prioritize the particular ones for that
that a particular president pathogens of
concern in terms of antibiotic
resistance so I've developed a quite a
big life of its own in its vets
well available on the website that's
used now in vast numbers of different
applications its value proposition
really is it enables you to in fact do
Christian is relatively economically and
relatively simple by simply enabling
well a really practical alternative
choices that's how it works okay
so you put a background here as to how
we get from the breeding objective to an
index so you'll hear and some of this
talk I'll be talking about most
development of the breeding objective
and affliction index we've used it for
both developing the breeding objective
which I said before is a profit function
and in the selection and the excess how
you get traits and put them into into a
breeding program into an actual breeding
program so what we do development of
affliction and it should simply take the
breeding objective you may all know this
I don't know what the backgrounds are
take it you define recordable heritable
traits that drive the outcome delivery
of the breeding objective you derive the
economic values for the change in
interest rate and then you create a
selection index very spoke to take you
through the steps let's look at British
a bit of sheep to things in sheep twins
are very very good and animals that grow
faster good
so what's the magic the breeding
objective and Sheikh the marginal change
in profit changing the revenue minus the
changing costs and the revenue I said
before comes from lamb meat surplus and
kill animals and from wool and the costs
come from animal health labor again now
in terms of revenue in a sheep business
it's actually quite easy to quantify
it's different it's not always the case
in a number of cases absolutely isn't so
the thousand Minds approach can work
both in revenue and in cost but in sheep
it's ronsley easy to get the revenue
side right it's the cost side which is
complex
so the revenue side numbers of lenss
born or weaned the growth rate to
slaughter or the way it slaughter and
their meat quality traits these are all
things that influence the revenue that a
farmer will get from a sheep block on
the cost side labor and health
treatments and feed feed costs and
perhaps reproduction cost
heritable traits that were used in the
friction index and they all and you can
see they come from the revenue in the
costs they come from the from the from
the the breeding objective so you can
look at the numbers of M's form what
what the an extra number extra lambourn
actually means to you what it means in
terms of the growth rate what it means
in terms of the costs all those sort of
things
and then the economic values and we do a
lot of work on driving economic babies
out of these by of economic models there
are expressed through unit change in the
trait and they assume of course in all
other things to hell he held constant at
the time and there's a lot of work on
bio mechanoid models in this sort of
stuff and Peter a my what about our guys
who was in their staff had promised a
lot of work in terms of development of
breeding objectives so here's a but then
we go from the breeding objective to the
friction from the economic values to the
selection index any reflection index
just says the economic value of numbers
of them's winged by the change in
numbers of LeAnn's wing plus set of
carcass weight cluster shocked by the
change in character stratum plus set in
disease resistance multiplied by disease
resistance and one of the really
important things is when you're doing
these things is to get the sign right so
disease resistance may be a have to be
very focused on getting the sign right
and some of those times the signs are
not always as intuitive as they look a
really good example is into carving
interval in in beef and dairy cows
getting the sign right and that one is
really very it can be quite complicated
logic so you've gotta be very careful so
why talk to users why bother
and see before economic models can be
deficient and meeting user needs and the
reason is because we're not you can't
get to the nuances of how people make
decisions and that may be regional it
may be it may be associated with
different regions may be associated with
where their markets are they do
different products there's different
things like that and so the objective
for the index may be different depending
on where you are and the other thing is
that understand better what farmers
really want to be beat improve beyond
the obvious economic traits now one of
the examples we view one of the
situations where we have used thousand
lines not in the breeding program design
but in a communication with farmers and
in designing an industry disease control
scheme has been with a disease called
Yanni's disease Mycobacterium
tuberculosis you only eye and it
was a particular problem in the New
Zealand deer and deer farm deer industry
it came in and of course some quote had
a particular problem and then the
industry put together their own control
scheme part of the communication about
that was how do you talk to farmers
about and he talked to farmers about the
problem how do you talk to farmers about
managing it how do you get near involved
and the thing there was that we did a
thousand mines and we found that the
farmer pursed the farm of view of the
cost of the disease was around twice as
twice or slightly more than twice the
actual economic cost of the disease to
them so in other words it had an impact
on how they behaved had impact on what
they could do your flexibility a whole
lot of things
so that's a really good example and why
do breeders wanted breeders want better
update and they want better sales and
they also want to improve their
long-term engagement with your customers
to grow their business that's why a
turbine
so what's different about talking to you
is the registered partners now I talk
about using the broader sense here
it may be farmers as users it may be
processors as users by product may be
anything but it changes the traditional
economic approach and introduces some
new tools for plant and animal breeders
they were you to quantify the views of
farmers and other partners to enable you
to develop new approaches to breeding
that might actually be better for
communication with the people that are
actually buying your product or buying
the breed or buying the new animals or
the new plants or whatever it recognizes
that people's views go beyond dollars
however what that enables them to do can
actually be a key part which may not be
fully accounted for in economic model
and it provides insights into whether
there are subgroups of farmers or
subgroups of people and and what might
drive this and also present
opportunities for breeding companies and
they're going to give you example of
so how do we do it and in fact the the
principles of how we do it are here so
fundamentally we do it through an online
survey and we've used that in in Nigeria
Ricky is using it with an interview
based approach can we done with that in
Ireland we use an interview based
approach for people people present you
use a number of different ways but we do
over time we've introduced the
demographic survey into the thing and
demographics not thousand lines that we
link the demographic survey with the
with the thousand mind survey we're just
about to launch one for honey bees but
breeders of honey bees and queen bee
gees of breed queens queen bees and the
users of honey bee honey bees for the
honey or pollination and one of the key
things here is to understand what groups
we're with him are we working with
people are interested in pollination are
we interested in working with groups
allergies and honey are we interested
working with those that are in very high
value honey or those that are in
standard important thing and the
respondents trade preferences are the
farmer or other and their perception of
their value of change in the trade this
will be a thousand Minds for our output
a choice patterns or preferred product
profiles in dollar equivalents for
traits we don't always do dollar
equivalent sometimes we're just happy
with the with the preference profile
depends on the trait on them on site on
the on the organization we're working
and we can crust the users into typology
which means and I'll give an example of
that in in for an Australian dairy
industry in a minute and thing but in in
the some of the plant breeders we found
that there was a difference between
breeders and everybody else in terms of
the importance of sealing you know seeds
hella important for breeders because
after did you see but it's a not what
farmers want because of the this is up
with quality so late flowering and rye
grass is wonderful farmers but terrible
for brain is because you may miss you
you may miss your ryegrass crop are
those sort of affliction those sort of
conflicts things are important
so go on now
the demographic survey here's their
demographic survey things that we look
at this is one I think oh this is a this
is a project we've just done in Poland
with dairy cattle in Poland which is
rights in limits I can't read and and it
was incorporate factors that might
influence other people's trade
priorities like farm size and location
what they thought about this
quantitative breeding misses the
traditional breeding of looking at
animals that they might think what
services aren't available how old they
are old they were or anything else that
might influence their preferences for
traits
you know talk a little bit about the
health what we do with thousand Minds
just to this high level before I go on
to some case studies and this is looking
at the trait preferences so the trait
Preferences need to be in readily now in
terms and it's critical to get the
direction of the trait right what's the
better choice I'll come back and talk
about things in a minute this is a
really nice example of whether there is
no better choice this is you can either
have a cheaper coffee we're gonna have a
stronger coffee but and so fundamentally
it contrasts a contrast a a much cheaper
coffee with a week of coffee and in fact
this this is entirely a preference based
approach this is nothing that there is
nothing here
you cannot tell me that anybody knows
which is the better charlie individual
approach so in such a situation we were
trying to make this quantitative we're
dealing with one at the moment in ear
honeybee thing we were really trying to
understand we're really trying to puzzle
their way through where we got a trait
which depends that may well depend
entirely on the demographic as to
whether that's a good trait or a bad
trait depending which is the most
preferred trait so he may well run a
separate a separate survey we're not
sure yet he'll do it may well run a
separate survey where they're dealt with
separately first and then we categorize
our groups and then administer the right
so major we're not sure yet how we're
going to do it but we're dealing there
with a lot of a lot of response so we're
not sure so now
the trade-off this is where most of the
time comes in developing thousand Minds
what to say administering the survey and
analyzing the data is easy comparable
suspect this is the bit where we spend a
lot of time this is actually get
developing the questionnaire developing
the survey really work we spend a lot of
time on it and we use we use experienced
people and we test the survey with some
we test the we try and get rid of
ambiguities with the Christians we make
some the questions very simple and we're
getting more and more focus on making
the comparisons incredibly simple you'll
see some of the early ones he done are
not that simple
it depends to who you're talking to if
you're talking to a very experienced
group its listeners so defining the
trade-offs so we use experienced
practitioners we run pilots we assess
the consistency of response for
individuals in time so we may we may run
the same survey with the same
individuals over three days over a week
for argument sake and just look at how
they with a bare consistent if they're
not consistent you start looking at your
worded the christians so it's quite
invertible we've spent a lot of time
getting this right this is one we've
just done this is the american angus one
well if we had 1500 families and people
in the industry involved in this one so
there's an online phone when I'm wearing
group meeting lots of different ways so
now in terms of what you get in terms of
outputting
as I said before this is some of the
outputs just looking at the outputs the
choice patterns the preferred product
profile and the equivalents in the
dollar equivalents for traits and the in
clustering of users so here's an
incident sort of a one I think this
looks like you but stuff we got out of
the canoe Australian dairy one we got
him up with a trait ranking we compare
preferences to impact evaluations so we
can put economic names and then we did
the group analysis we came up with our
priori groups where we actually thought
there might be something for example
people who had more black and white
Carroll versus other Carol we use PCA
and cluster analysis performed typology
and then we looked at what the
of the demographic maybe a
distinguishing between typologies and
the case the Australian dairy
that wasn't very that there was there
weren't any demographic components but
there were differently groups of
topologies that came up that changed the
way the people marketed their products
what are we used it for the first
project we really did was looking at
sheep in Ireland we did that in there
two thousand seven eight nine then we
did pasture plants Kevin Smith and I Kim
Smith now University of Melbourne and I
did a project in grass and legumes we've
used on dairy cattle in Australia New
Zealand I'll talk about the dairy cattle
one Angus cattle in us and now in Canada
just starting a honeybees one in New
Zealand and as you know we've got the
cassava one in Nigeria in Uganda and
sweet potato with EIB in Uganda as well
and we've looked at in Farmer priorities
in diseases and understanding other
things okay I'm getting the two case
studies which goes through the first
affliction and dekes development in the
dairy industry and the second is felling
valuing difficult traits in dry grass
breeding Australian dairy industry why
rates to it why we did it because it why
the Australian data gene which is the
Australian dairy hood improvement scheme
did it is because they were getting
feedback from their customers that they
were questioning the relevance of what
they were getting out so that was the
issue and they would potentially think
they could lose customers so they were
interested and obviously in getting the
genetic improvement scheme is going what
robustly and well so what traits to
include should there be multiple indices
what should the trait weighting speed
and how did this would this have any
impact on the design of breeding
programs or marketing programs now this
is this is a this is how it works in a
preference based system this is taking
straight out trade-off of Epica
trade-offs here would you prefer to have
eight less lameness patients per 100
cows a year doesn't matter what they are
or one more lactation per cow because
when cows fall out of a herd they fall
out partly because of lameness that's it
and you can no you choose one or the
other what this does is roots of Lee is
that it goes through and ask questions
asks a whole lot of questions and based
on the answer to your previous questions
it will come back and select another
another question but there's always a
contrast of a trade-off
so it's a trade-off as the important
point this is obviously
big survey it's got 78 questions a lot
of them that we develop around the 28 to
35 Christians for a farmer here's
another one
1.5 kilograms of more protein per cow
per year versus 1% less feed per cow
these these in this survey what's been
done here in a bio economic models
because these are relatively simple in a
bio economic sense to make them
equivalent financially you don't need to
do this we don't we didn't do that in
the past the one we don't it's much
better if you don't have to make them
equivalent you get much more power in
your survey this one's used using it the
vet the financials come out of the
equivalents their maturity in my view if
you can avoid using them and use
financial levels they're more powerful
but sometimes you have to do it
depending on the other ways your surveys
get too complicated this is the outcome
the relative preferences you can see it
goes like that rates 13 rates about 7%
so fundamentally in the average there's
a bit I'm monitoring more it's there
might be more traits in that model so
the average is about 7% in you can see
that mastitis longevity and fertility
and so the the top usually you find the
top quarter of your traits are going to
be significantly different from the from
the from the expected mean about that so
the noble sure to do it and then the
bottom won't fall out or the same same
background
if some just breaks you can see the the
variances are quite large and then what
you try and do is see if any of you any
of your demographics or your groups
being take down take those out this is
the this is the this this is a different
type of the group this is greeting now
and two three types of traits in dairy
cattle
you've got the functional traits which
are things that that really cause people
to kill animals like their mastitis
lameness fertility in production traits
milking how long it takes to milk a cow
as a production of milk a protein
production of fat the amount of feed an
animal eats and then the type traits are
those farmers regard as important or
have come to intuitions about are
important for their performance they
might be things like at a placement
which is actually quite important in in
robotic milking or in milking we we've
got robotic
putting on cups robotically
an idea of clustering this clustering
lead to an outcome for the industry this
is data genes friction index result so
what we did here on that I don't need to
take too much noting that most of what
they all the number sir but on the left
was their original was the what they
started off with a single index they
came they came and they now offer three
different indexes you'll see that the
green was productivity and their
previous index was about sixty percent
and you'll see in all of the others
productivity is Nellie's what's actually
happened is that she'll count
in other words that's associated with
mastitis there's some increased in
importance and one or two other traits
have as well and slightly increased in
performance but the important point is
that it's led to three different indexes
and these are now marketed by David buy
these are now marketed by the breeding
companies David genes service company
behind the whole thing
please now markedly the companies have
now three different indexes so the
animals are either the Bulls which the
farmers by seeming for you can either
buy them on high ranking for balanced
performance or high ranking for a health
weighted index or a high rated for a
tight basin so it's changed the way the
the company's market their things so
what they do is they mock no might be
the same bull but there are three
different rankings for it and three
different in three different outcomes
three different applications like seeds
now going to give you an example
that's been that's gone into the
industry now get your example the one
which really has not been taken up in
any obvious way by the industry and it's
in relation to breeding of pasture
species it was done in Kevin Smith and
Ida listen I think we published this two
papers 2011 and 2014 um what we do here
why it's a complexity why do we do it
why do we why they want us to do it
because the complexity defining relative
values and traits fought for these
highly competitive businesses and the
fundamental leaders they are around
growing the market and they have a
consortium to grow the market but then
they fight over market share so they
unite to grow the market but they fight
over market share so they're trying to
get a point of difference maybe part of
the reason why there's got no way up leg
is not over it so there are monetary
values but rates what we're interested
in is can you derive monetary values for
traits are difficult to exist
financially what will influence farmers
decisions why do they buy relative
weightings to apply inflection and
implications in both breeding and
marketing programs understanding more
about the family what they Matt what
they sell this is what you call a
willingness to pay approach in here here
you work around a parameter that says
okay how much is I prepared to pay how
much I agreed to pay extra for this
particular trait therefore you need an
anchor trait that can be valued
economically and there are some
characteristics of getting this anchor
trait right are very important this is
what we've learned so after a lot of
difficulty we actually a lot of going
and frying talking to a lot of people
Karen and I came up with the value of
pasture yield as being the anchor trait
and people said it was early spring some
people said it was anyway we were in the
end we did a survey across four seasons
spring summer autumn winter in three
environments
temperate high rainfall in Mediterranean
environments
and we expressed it and that anchor we
used was something that [ __ ] if we did
this in Australia farmers are very used
to doing they compensate for their
capacity by using grain and grains got a
define price this in the markets higher
at the moment but it's got a defined
placement so we were able to use that as
the value through income so then we went
through we did the survey right and we
this is the this is the question we did
this was a to survey model so he said ok
and you'll see here it's a willingness
to pay it's a willingness to pay
alternative option so you've got no
change in Spring yield and increased
autumn yield above the 2 ton of grain on
that side and the Contra is increased
spring yield from the one change of
grain or increased autumn you were
coming to one ton of grain so in other
words it's 2 ton of grain in the autumn
that's one in each which people prefer
and that's the power of that's the power
of the thing so doing all that we came
up with some very interesting things you
can see it just going across the top
spring 25 60 average spring is not
important to anybody the grass always
grows in spring even in even in a
Mediterranean client even late rain
you're probably going to get rain even
if you didn't get chemistry if you don't
give it an April May and in the South
Australia you're likely to get it
sometime in the winter so spring is
going to be reliable a thing that's not
reliable in is autumn and winter and at
least on summer so you can see that
right
pointers that spring yields this
important than other seasons and some of
yours relatively more important than the
high-ranked all zone then in the
Mediterranean zone because in the
Mediterranean time they've got they take
their animals off they don't have from
the in the and in the summer in autumn
the when they've got their animals
mating time they want they want to have
really good yields I wonder autumn
reliable so that gives you an idea the
logic is there but we have to quantify
the logic what we do in the end because
the we actually chose autumn yield this
is an example of autumn yield and
fundamentally we check for linearity and
we check for linearity within within
individual responses this is the means
that we check for linearity within the
individual responses so we do a
covariant model just to check for
linearity obviously I was is as one two
and three ton of grain its retailing
grain worth basically three times as
much then you can come up with some
numbers and so for argument's sake the
preference value of a hunt of per
hundred dollars of grain is three point
four percent in other words that's a
proof and you sit in the complete survey
it's about three point four to see that
the mean prestige preference value for a
ton of grain was eight point six percent
so we weren't able to work this out in
the next stage of the survey and then
you can say okay what's the dollar value
for one percent preference to a year and
it came out to twenty nine dollars
fundamentally and over the three
environments that was much the same
which is why we in fact chose autumn
mule because it's actually much the same
that's really important that we were
able to use it the same parameter
across all three and we're able to use
the same forever to us all three and
across all of four species
that's the value of you so we used
autumn you as the financial benchmark as
the anchor trait it enables us to
qualify the quantify the value of other
traits against autumn you and I'm going
to give you three examples persistence
which is a straight-out
persistence is regarded by farmers
buying to replace pasture place
perennial pastures as a critical factor
so we've put in the two for no change in
persistence and extra two years of we
have to resew four years or six years so
it's a really critical factor for these
guys and then we looked at two other
traits survival under adverse conditions
which is actually around alimony and
water logging in those it's actually
important loosen alfalfa particularly
important and then summer survival which
is particularly important with perennial
rye grasses in the temperate temperate
region because with the increasing
temperatures you get more days over 25
to 27 degrees with my grass perennial
ryegrass starts to suffer
subtly important I'm just going
these are like a bit of thinking about
so I don't want to take too much time so
there's no change in so what we've got
here no change in autumn yield or
increased autumn yield per hectare come
to 500 tonnes of grain now very subtly
we had to check to get the consistency
here we had to go from two ton of grain
to the monetary value but we told them
at the start what we were using but we
had to make it put it into qualified
even though in the previous their way of
Duns and tons to get the equilibration
across the seasons in the environments
here we had to put it into dollars to
make it real so it was important and the
imposter is more persistent now and
lasts two years longer than their or
pasture lasts the same the time is now
so you can see pair of Christians and a
pair of priestess
people get quite fast at answering these
they say Oh help I absolutely need more
persistence no matter what it costs but
that's what they do
or they might say no I they might think
more and they say I need fan autumn
kills me I need more money more an order
so that they get quite fast and
answering them and then listen I'll
trade off this is actually past year
this was Australia yes or no one really
passed you always survives in adverse
conditions salt were longing and a high
element and there is another Australian
comparison and this is a persistence
survival and hot dry summer which as I
mentioned is really important for
ryegrass
you
doesn't like going back this machine
it's what we find found that the you can
see along the top as I said before the
autumn yield for 1% preference for years
you have the same number the value of an
extra year of persistence we convert
this to financial values and you can see
an extra year of persistence is not
worth nearly only worth half as much in
a minute Deranian environment as it's
worse as it's worth in a hybrid as a
high rainfall environment but people
that they actually don't they don't need
to say that off so persistent they just
in there rely on annuals and the annual
self seed just a lot of terribly
surprising thing because they've got a
lot of annual species the real problem
with real thing with these guys is when
they want to introduce a new species
it's a very big distance and they'll
often introduce a different species
rather than them prove the same
and then the value of guaranteed
survival you see in the temperate in the
temperate situation with ryegrass that
the value of guaranteed survival under
in particulars relates of salt actually
insult is actually worth a lot more for
ryegrass
and then you get into survival and hot
dry summers again you'll see that that
the that guaranteed survival in hot dry
summers despite what we thought that
this would be a real really really
important thing for people in the in the
in the temperate areas where you've got
a lot of business fun lot of ryegrass
before to be really important it's not
as important I think we did the survey
again now after three years in southern
Victoria a very high summer temperatures
and ryegrass died I think we feared
differently with well see a very
different so it's very interesting as to
what actually happens and so you can put
a leash into context I'll just do this
one here the they mcgahren teach
survival and adverse conditions of
friend and success cooked 1.2 great tons
of grain in a temperate and temperate
environment or 2.1 tons of grain in a
high rainfall environment they can get
out and use it
so the principles that we go through
here that priorities can evolve over
time and I think that survival and hot
dry summers will be one of them and but
it gives an opportunity to engage with
farmers and other users such as bias to
understand their wants and needs it
ensures the breeding program priorities
align with user needs so it's a way of
talking about talking about why you've
done something Vickie and mark I would
say a lot of us is about a marketing
tool for people for their companies and
it builds and it could also help
influence how people communicate their
message to the users and it aims to
build product profiles and section tools
to help boost adoption which is the same
same thing which is a recent the
rationale behind the work with with
nicotine cassava so what I only see and
cassava where does it fit if I hit the
top three of them just the same who
farmers woman in the family buyers in
the market the sellers of cassava steam
companies they're the people that might
have
so I'm somebody what I've talked to me
or we've been about evidence about why
we've done survey basically that's where
we've got to bearing among we've been
involved in this now for just over ten
years and we're getting where we've
learned a lot and we're still aren't
there but we've learned a lot
why engage with users a little bit about
the approach and how we've integrated
demographic surveys which are very
important actually and did a couple of
applications and where it goes to with
next-gen Kesava okay
[Applause]
yeah it says here that if I look at the
fruit like the seed companies and you
feel like you're always marketing to
probably you're marketing to dairy
farmers versus Hill Country guys versus
yeah those other two big clusters right
and so fundamentally you've almost got a
different you may have a your type of
rye grass you might offer to one maybe
subtly different for example the late
flowering rye grass is probably worth a
lot more to a hill country sheep and
beef farmer than exists to a dairy
farmer who can manage pastures by
grazing control so it really comes down
you might have the same product you
might have the same you might have the
same um she said of rye grasses but you
just you might market them different I
think it's a horses for courses to be
honest it's an important question I
don't know I don't know as any blanket
answer it's just but you don't need to
the things aren't met precise there that
helps not did we get rid of I think what
we do yeah what we do this is why I
emphasize that early stage thing right
we've been a huge amount of time during
the Christian and we've had three work
three workshops for example on the honey
anyone to date there like a thing three
workshops with different people going
through to complications to complicated
cutting up seven words or you know so we
fundamentally and then we test it again
and test it again because you can't you
mess up your and
when you do thousand Minds it comes up
with an estimate of a number of
questions and the amount of time at the
bottom because your does does a dozen
model model and it doesn't prediction so
it's actually very powerful right and it
means a lot of who you're dealing with
dealing with specialists you can have a
lot more questions and you can go for
twenty minutes you're dealing with
farmers or something like you might want
the under eight to ten or twenty five
questions okay but eighteen the gay
teens are really quite good number four
and you can't do too many levels so you
can be really careful about the
subtleties it the levels are the power
of the power you put into the model to
actually get the financial fifty eight
levels and the financials it's a lit
with the linearity or she comes exactly
right here well that's actually one of
the things that that the that they we're
not sure what's going to come out of
women discussions was I see be if I
believe over the arms dear are a sheep
one is to him effectively that's about
adoption I mean it's more about are they
adopting are they taking notice of the
index this is not taking notice someone
which is a key thing right
what and of course the Irish do they've
got some the post really cunning on how
they've introduced incentives from them
to uptake of genetics in Ireland but
usually you eat you subsidies to do that
best money the first stone in case study
in its own right so it may not be the
best market i think that the australian
when we come to it after about the
Australians are be had two years now of
selling this way thinking we come to do
it analysis to see what actually to see
what how what whether the whether the
proportion whether they got increased
uptake would be the probably the best
one and in the in the next game cassava
when we've had discussions about do we
take the survey and there's an
individual level because won't have
giant turned to influence a breeding
program inside a reduced PhD do we
actually now go out and see what people
are etched
that's one of the parts of the Reiki I
don't sure where it's gotcha but I
haven't talked to her ready for two
months because she's been away but but
that's what we're thinking near as we go
out and see what they're actually buying
and see if it's more influence for
example by the guy doing selling the
cuttings yeah but there's one of the
things that thousand minds tries to do
is to keep on asking the Christian if
you get Piske units not giving you a
clean answer that keeps on going back
willingness to pay is a thought it's
totally forties you know yeah but it's
um it's better then it's better than not
knowing that's the best description
certainly the farmers and the in the one
with the youngish disease they like the
idea that they were they they
individually understood that this was
much bigger than the economic they're
having a something they could say
actually we like that it actually means
it's a very important Christian I don't
know the answer I come I can't now you
got you're going you'd worked with if I
came to us we would say we're doing a
survey of your customers we've worked
with it we'd work with their client
motion I think yeah I think niche about
what they you know we bought one for
example and ryegrass you've got one he's
quite big on recurrence fiction and the
other one he's very big on bringing in
different different ecotypes they've got
two quite contrasting quite contrasting
strategies but equally if you go and
examine the genetic see their cultivars
you'll find they've used each other
stuff in their own background you know
so but generally what we work with we
work with the individual the group
became a customer to saw it defines
whether they we would normally go to
customers I can only talk about
reactance we just need to do what they
like I'm not sure I think it's been
moderately successful oh yeah yeah fresh
all traits rust busting my grasses just
to get it last so wheat the breed is
just there's no rust Christian I don't I
don't there's a rattle I mean wasn't as
Christian initially but it's irrelevant
because it's just a killing trade full
stop culling trait another one is
another one's establishment which is a
big issue in rye grass I mean you
totally intolerant reasoning doesn't a
certain tall fescue it's got to take
time see you so tall fescue for example
it's definitely I says no real economic
place because everything is good until
fiscal it's got huge economic because
it's not all in so going for yes
absolutely so then we just call them
threshold preach and they go out that's
why we were really interested in this
excellent survival these absolute those
absolute survival ones ones that hot dry
environment one and the adverse of
moment were designed to see if there
were threshold traits we were missing
yeah so that's why we yeah they don't
really go in the breeding objective they
just they end up us they just Road
it's a roadie model
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu